[Music]
Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott getting
candid like never before
Stormy's parents are the cover stars on
the August issue of GQ showing Kylie
straddling her man in their first joint
photo shoot inside the mag the couple
opened up about their notoriously
private relationship and Parenthood
Kylie says days into knowing each other
she decided to join Travis on tour after
his Coachella stop
quote he said I'm going back on tour we
obviously liked each other and I was
like I guess I'm going with you do
something fun since starting their
whirlwind romance Kylie has tried to
keep their relationship out of the
spotlight apparently the Goosebumps
rapper isn't a fan of the attention that
comes with dating a kardashian-jenner
Kylie explained quote that's why we just
go the extra mile to keep our
relationship super private adding I
don't think he's really cool with it but
he deals with it because we love each
other and we have a family now the two
share five month old daughter stormy and
Travis admits the last time he cried was
in the delivery room when his little
girl was born as for the Kardashian
curse referring to the many public break
ups the women of the family have had
travis admits he's not nervous about it
quote nervous for what I'm on my own
Island I'm not into all the other I
don't get involved I'm over here
kylie is different
you
[Applause]
[Music]